[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the theory that
Professor Alber Dumbledore famed Wizard
and beloved Headmaster of Hogwarts was
not actually a wizard at all but death
incarnate if you're familiar with the
final installment of the Harry Potter
series then you're likely well aware of
the death the Hallows after all that
final installment in both novel and film
form is called the Deathly Hallows but
just to make sure that we're all on the
same page here's a quick recap of what
the infamous Deathly Hallows are where
they came from and what they stand for
the Deathly Hallows are three fabled
magical artifacts all of which are
featured in a rather popular children's
book within the Wizarding World called
the tales of beetle The Bard included in
a collection of similar Stories the
Fable is known as the tale of the Three
Brothers in which there are three clever
Wizards all of whom are you guessed it
Brothers as the story goes in attempting
to cross a dangerous river the men used
their magic to make it safely to the
other side death who was used to
claiming the lives of those who tried to
cross this particular River was Furious
that the three brothers had not perished
in their Crossing in an effort to try
and take their souls at a later date
death appeared before the men and
pretended to congratulate them offering
them Gifts of their ch
all of which had the capacity to hold
incredible Powers the eldest brother an
arrogant power hungry wizard asked for a
wand stronger than any other that very
same day after using what would become
known in Legend as the Elder Wand to
duel and defeat another wizard the
eldest brother happily fell asleep only
to be murdered in the night the W stolen
Before Dawn the second brother whose
beloved had died not long before meeting
death asked for an item that could bring
people back from the dead death granted
him a stone the resurrection stone that
was able to do just that and the brother
used it to bring his former beloved back
to the world of the living what the
Middle Brother hadn't anticipated was
how miserable his former lover would be
in a world that she no longer belonged
to she was cold and separated from him
by a veil and so instead of continuing
to suffer in this world without her in
her material form he took his own life
and joined her in death
the youngest brother was a much humbler
man than his older brothers and did not
seek an additional way to best death
instead he asked for a way to hide from
Death so that he could live out the rest
of his life peacefully to fulfill this
request death reluctantly gave the
youngest brother the most powerful cloak
of invisibility ever known to exist one
that even death couldn't see through and
so as The Story Goes the two older
brothers lost their lives to death soon
after crossing the river in which they
had first bested him but the youngest
brother lived out a long and happy life
eventually taking the cloak off to greet
death as an old friend and passing the
invisibility cloak onto his son of
course this is just a fable and I'm sure
the author took Liberties in the way in
which he told the story but there has
been substantial proof to support that
the tale of the Three Brothers was based
on real Wizards in fact Harry Ron and
herione themselves uncovered the long
history of who the brothers may have
been and whether or not the magical
artifacts were real during their hunt
for Voldemort's HW reers in what would
have been their final year at Hogwarts
the trio discovered that the peral
brothers Antioch Cadmus and ignotus were
likely the inspiration behind the taale
not long after they also discovered that
one of the Dark Lord's Haw ruxers was
actually the resurrection Stone they
even learned that Alba Dumbledore had
knowingly been in possession of the
Elder one for some time as well not to
mention the fact that Harry came into
possession of one of the Deathly Hallows
himself at the mere age of 11 the
invisibility cloak this leads us to the
question of if the brothers were real
what about death while it may seem
rather unlikely that three Wizards
actually came up against death incarnate
stranger things have happened in the
Wizarding World of Harry Potter so who
was death what did he look like where
did he go is he still around toying with
Muggles and wizards alike to me these
seem like reasonable questions
considering what we know so far yet if
you were to have asked Wise Old
Professor Albert Dumbledore as Harry did
he likely would have told you what he
told Harry I think it more likely that
the peral brothers were simply gifted
dangerous Wizards who succeeded in
creating those powerful objects in other
words according to Dumbledore death was
not a person but simply a concept
designed by the author of the tale of
the Three Brothers to make an exciting
narrative but wouldn't that be a
convenient thing to say for someone who
perhaps knew more than they were letting
on and didn't want anyone to know the
truth for what if Professor Albert
Dumbledore was death in many tales death
with a capital D is not an actual human
being but a concept or force in the
world that rules over and thrives on the
death of people in the tale of the Three
Brothers how however he is the
personification of death he is
recognizable to the Wizards as death
incarnate and answers to the name by
which he is known so wouldn't that mean
that if death took on a physical form he
would be recognizable as death I don't
necessarily think so what if over the
centuries he chose to be a little more
discreet this would make sense since
when he met the paral brothers it was
the 13th century and all things mystical
and Magic were a little more out in the
open but by the time that the 20th
century rolled around the international
statute of secrecy had been in effect
for about 300 years and if death was an
actual presence in the world that can
take on a physical form and communicate
with the living I would imagine that as
time went on he would have found that he
needed to be a little more careful I
personally think that over the centuries
death would have met with Mortals in
many different forms of course at first
he started off in his true material form
as death incarnate as the several
Brothers met him but as time went on and
he had to be more discreet he started to
change his appearance in order to not
become a target of both mugle society
and The Wizarding World in the late
1880s what if he decided to wreak havoc
by entering the world as a member of The
Dumbledore family assuming the form of
one alus peral wolfi Brian Dumbledore as
Albus it was given the opportunity to
toy with the imaginings of a young power
hungry G grinder World fueling his
Ambitions for total control of the
Wizarding World and leading him to the
idea of the three Fable gifts that he as
death had once bestowed upon the peral
brothers and if grindlewald had been
successful in its attempts to take over
Muggles in magical Society imagine just
how much death there would have been on
git's way to Glory as it were there was
already so Much Death at the hands of
grindlewald in his attempt to rise to
power what a victory for death himself
and how could we forget how Dumbledore
set up our boy Harry for sacrificial
Slaughter at the hands of Voldemort for
years he helped Mentor him in order to
send him off to die at the hands of the
darkest wizard the world had seen since
grinder Wald isn't it interesting that
Dumbledore seemed to be the center of
both grinder Wald and Voldemort's
ascents to power not to mention that
Alber Dumbledore was the one who gave
Harry the invisibility cloak just as he
did with ignotus peral centuries
beforehand now if you're thinking that
this all seems a bit elaborate and
twisted consider the fact that death has
been taking lives since the beginning of
time it stands to reason that over the
Millennia he's gotten a bit bored this
is clearly showcased in his overly
complex plan to take the lives of the
peral brothers why would Death trick
them into thinking they had defeated him
and to give them gifts that would be
their eventual demise at least in the
case of the two older brothers if he
very likely could have just killed them
on the spot I think he did this for the
exact same reason that he decided to
embody a wizard for over a century and
to bring about death in extravagant and
elaborate ways he wanted to challenge
another piece of evidence that supports
this theory is the presence of three
Wizards in Dumbledore's life during the
latter half of the 20th century that
seemed to mirror the three pereral
brothers that is would it makees sense
if death continuously recreated
situations in which the players
represented similar things to him even
if by accident the similarities that are
referencing here are between Lord
Voldemort and the eldest peral brother
Antioch SE Snape and Cadmus peval the
middle brother and Harry Potter and the
youngest brother
ignotus a theory all unto its own these
similarities are actually quite striking
with the dark lord and Antioch both
being obsessed by the idea of power and
wanting to overcome death it's also
interesting to note that they both held
the Elder one at some point within their
lives Snape and Cadmus on the other hand
were both consumed by the loss of the
woman they loved for Snape it was Lily
Evans Harry's mom and for Cadmus it was
his deceased
fiance in both instances these two men
allowed their emotions to dictate how
they lived and died finally there's
Harry and ignotus this comparison is
really quite simple especially since
Harry is presumably the ancestor of
ignotus pevl and they both owned the
invisibility cloak and overcame the
pursuit of death ignot just did so by
using the cloak to hide from Death while
Harry did so by offering himself up to
die only to survive the killing curse
for the second time in his life not to
mention the fact that Dumbledore had a
part in the deaths of both Voldemort and
Snape just as death did with Antioch and
Cadmus and with that we've come to the
end of another video what did you think
do you agree that alus Dumbledore could
have actually been death himself please
share your thoughts in the comments
below and as always if you enjoyed this
video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to the channel also be sure to
check out the content on Spotify as well
as extra content on my second Channel
Harry Potter Theory extra until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
[Music]
live